So here we have a sample of vanadium. So vanadium
is used to do catalysis, it is used for a
whole range of different things.
So vanadium is the third of the transition
metals and, because it has more electrons,
it has really quite interesting chemistry.
It is also used in nature and there are a
number of mushrooms that are vanadium rich.
The amavadins especially is one of the materials.
So here if we open, we can see on our reel
is a very nice sample of vanadium wire. So
this is the elemental vanadium and as you
can see it is about 0.1 mm in diameter and
there is 20 metres of it on this reel.
Some of its compounds are very reactive. I
can remember that my lab mate Paul was working
with a compound called vanadium hexacarbonyl.
He got a sample it was quite expensive, and
he poured it, it came in a sealed glass vessel
so he cut open the glass and poured it out
and before his eyes it burst into flames and
disappeared.